bonjour bonjour
les amis tout ce qu'ils sortent ici un
semblant de normalité qui font loi pour
cette ukrainienne habitués enseigné à
plus de 2000 kilomètres de la côte
d'azur travail à la chaire de langue
étrangère à l'institut de relations
internationales
et début de l'invasion russe le 24
février elle est partie de kiev avec sa
fille pour se déplacer de ville en ville
dans l'ouest du pays on ne pouvait pas
trouver du calme oui
même quand nous sommes arrivés
finalement près de lviv même là donc
oudry des bombardements elles ont quitté
l'ukraine à la mi mars pour la france
aborda watts et c'est bafé seraient
venus ici parce qu'une organisation
qu'elle connaissait lui a proposé de
donner des cours bénévolement à d'autres
réfugiés et c'était un grand soulagement
oui pour moi parce que partira vers
l'inconnu c'est une chose mais quand tu
pars et du sien environ ce qui va se
passer c'est une autre chose en échange
la ville fournit un logement
tania réside avec sa fillette chez l'une
des nombreuses familles d'accueil elle
s'émerveille encore de ce qui les
attendait à leur arrivée un coin aménagé
avec cuisine lit draps propres un repas
chaud
un miracle tél
nice est la france toute entière ouvrent
grand leur coeur et leurs bras aux
ukrainiens diverses infrastructures sont
mises à contribution
des milliers d'autorisations provisoires
de séjour sont octroyés des milliers
d'enfants sont scolarisés
on leur donne des vêtements on donne des
produits d'hygiène on donne des produits
de première nécessité on leur trouve un
hôtel et puis ensuite on met en place un
accompagnement sur le plus longtemps on
regarde si jamais ils ont besoin de voir
un médecin a suivi avec un psychologue
s'ils désirent apprendre le français
s'ils cherchent un travail 40% des
ukrainiens qui transitent par la route
passe par les alpes maritimes selon les
autorités du département la remarquable
solidarité à leur égard est largement
salué alors que celle manifestée envers
d'autres arrivant ne suscite pas
toujours le même engouement
à 1h30 dans miss cédric et rouen offre
chez lui des activités et un toit à des
gens en grande précarité sociale ou
légal
il avait connu des déboires judiciaires
après avoir transporté depuis l'italie
frontalière quelques 200 migrants venus
notamment du soudan et de l'erythrée en
2016 ensuite je fais arrêter avec des
personnes qui fut également la guerre il
a été condamné avant d'être
définitivement acquittés après cinq ans
de procès de multiples garde à vue des
perquisitions j'étais devenu l'ennemi
public numéro un en france parce que
j'ai des gens et là d'un coup d'un coup
du jour au lendemain même les partis
d'extrême droite disent à bout il faut
les accueillir ces gens qui vivent la
guerre et on voit qu'en fait si on
arrive si on a envie d'arriver à faire
les choses encadré chose on y arrive son
association emmaüs croyais à a récemment
manifesté devant cette gare où des
contrôles réguliers traquer les
sans-papiers elle réclame un accueil
universel et inconditionnel exilés ont
gardé c'est tous ces services qu'on a
gardé ouvertes pour les personnes en
migration qui vivent la guerre en
ukraine secret bien gardé ses structures
en place pour accueillir les autres gens
l'an dernier plus de vingt mille
migrants auraient été refoulés des alpes
maritimes vers l'italie leur point
d'entrée en europe
et dizaines de milliers de personnes qui
ont fuit l'ukraine sont arrivés en
france
l'urgence les horreurs et la proximité
de cette guerre sont évoqués pour
expliquer les noms de solidarité ici la
certitude et l'incertitude et il y a
plus selon cette philosophe qui préside
une association vouée à l'intégration de
réfugiés et de demandeurs d'asile de
tous horizons tendre la main à quelqu'un
c'est faire un acte politique de soutien
et de dénonciation et je pense qu'il ya
ça aussi c'est à dire que les français
en accueillant chez eux de cette manière
irréfléchie déraisonnable quasiment
voyez les femmes et les enfants
ukrainiens c'était une manière de
soutenir leurs
la robe résistance
[Musique]
trouvait loin dit 'tiens un peu de
réconfort un s'occupa c'est une joie
aussi parce que je vois ces personnes là
qui commence à sourire qui commence
aussi à retrouver leur propre calme
ici anick bérard et du canada dans les
alpes-maritimes